como si se tratara de una versión
moderna de romeo y julieta esta pareja
disfruta de un breve encuentro al otro
lado de la valla y no nos vemos desde el
3 de enero solo nelson así aunque solo
puedo verle así es bueno verla no
caballo pues por ella hay otros
voluntarios de los juegos de beijing han
pasado semanas dentro de una burbuja
olímpica el estricto sistema consiguió
mantener a raya el virus reivindicando
la política china de cero kobe pero los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de 2022
pasarán a la historia como uno de los
más controvertidos comenzó con una serie
de gobiernos occidentales que anunciaron
un boicot diplomático por el historial
de supuestas violaciones de derechos
humanos de china varios atletas fueron
descalificados tras dar positivo por
kobe 19 y otros se enfrentaron a
condiciones de entrenamiento restrictivo
las pistas de esquí se cubrieron de
nieve artificial pero el mayor legado de
los juegos olímpicos de beijing será el
escándalo de dopaje de la patinadora
artística de 15 años caminaba lieva no
pasó un control antidopaje en diciembre
pero resultado no se reveló hasta un día
después que la lleva ayudará a ganar el
oro en una prueba por equipos es muy
lamentable que debido al asunto del
dopaje del equipo ruso nuestros atletas
en la prueba de patinaje artístico por
equipos no puedan traer sus medallas a
casa la ceremonia de entrega de medallas
de esa competición se ha suspendido
alieva fue recibida como una heroína a
su regreso a rusia el viernes tras la
protesta por la decisión del tribunal de
arbitraje deportivo permitirle competir
en la prueba individual la patinadora se
doblegó ante la presión en el hielo la
forma en que su entrenadora trató a la
adolescente sollozante reprendiendo la
en lugar de consolarla ha conmocionado
al mundo y ha puesto en tela de juicio
el trato que rusia da a sus atletas